you can do this it's not hard tell her
how you feel
give it a call it and give it a card
tell how you feel
leave give her the card tell her how you
feel
move on hey man I believe in you
Thanks your your support means so much
oh yeah listen confronting your feelings
difficult stuff you should be proud of
yourself
put her there
[Music]
Hey
you're on time yeah aren't I always
not at all he relates to our graduation
I had trouble putting on my dress
I thought it was trafficked bottom line
is I'm here
where's rose Eric uh he's not coming
Oh is he uh he's sick no I just thought
it would be nice if it was them just the
two of us
[Music]
all right so I can't stay too long what
we made reservations I know I'm sorry
but they just have to take it what's
going on with you nothing it's never
been this bad what's never been this bad
it's it I just like things a certain way
yeah but it gets worse when you're
depressed fine I've been stressed so
depressed can you please just low
everybody welcome to Cafe Blas open mic
LA's best comedy
Who am I kidding none of this matters
you don't care I don't care all right
let's do this first guy Rhino baron
come on up here yeah get it I'm a white
man so what here
Michael you're out of your mind
sorry I can't accept this this is too
much it's fine it's uh it's what you
always wanted right but I wanted to get
it for myself
yeah but we've been friends for like
eight years it's fine then my mom told
me about how sick I make my dad I guess
that's why I can't smell heaven there
anymore Jesus Christ think of it as a
wedding here ah okay the next step we
have Terrence a baguette II
this morning I was and there was who is
it I can't accept this Maura
I need you to take this I got one
through too much for you to just reject
that was your decision you don't put
this on me it's always been on you it's
always been you have you talked to dr.
Lin recently you said yes I heard you
but as much as you wanna unload whatever
you're going through on me I'm not gonna
let you take the goddamn card
I believed in you man I'm gonna go call
dr. Lin yeah we'll check on you tomorrow
and if you just think about it use this
one brief moment I get to be up here
channeling you know all of these dreams
if someone has $100 I just need a
hundred bucks and that's it
[Music]
hello